[Music]
foreign
6 26 on your Halloween Monday morning
boy there are some big changes tonight
on Charleston at the 95 5 15.
as one of my broadcasting Heroes used to
say stand by for news Well we lost the
great Paul Harvey in 2009 so there's no
way he would have known about the
freeway system in Las Vegas but the
Nevada Department of transportation's
Justin Hopkins has news for anyone
driving on Charleston around the 95 5-15
the westbound lanes are being shut down
westbound drivers shifted into the
eastbound Lanes now in this video from
noon yesterday the Cones were just
sitting there ready for the big change
scheduled to last upwards of a year
and this morning everything's fine but
the cones are there the shifting is
scheduled to start tonight to learn more
about this project you want to check out
ndot's i515 charleston.com website that
is linked in the online version of this
story just visit 8newsnow.com clip
traffic they're driving you crazy buckle
up drive carefully please put down that
phone and you can join the driving to
Crazy conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com